Netflix, Amazon, Hulu, a theater near you—the
modern film fan has more choices than ever.
To help you sort through them all, we've taken
a hard look at this year's most critically
acclaimed features and assembled a list of
best bets. Here are some standouts of what
Hollywood had to offer in the first half of
2016.
Captain America: Civil War
Captain America: Civil War rounded up a hefty
assortment of Marvel Cinematic Universe favorites—and
some highly anticipated new faces. The result
is a thrilling, action-packed adventure of
superhero spectacle that even the most anti-comic
book film fan might enjoy.
The Witch
"Boo! There you are… Boo!"
It's hard to find a horror movie with enough
faith in its audience to take things slow
and get weird. The Witch, which unspools in
a spooky thicket of woods in 17th-century
New England, follows a familiar path. But
it's director Robert Eggers' flair for imagery
that makes The Witch so creepily compelling.
10 Cloverfield Lane
10 Cloverfield Lane uses 2008's Cloverfield
as the launchpad for the story of a woman,
played by Mary Elizabeth Winstead, who flees
a busted engagement only to run into disaster.
She ends up locked in an underground shelter
by a man, played by an unhinged John Goodman,
who insists the Earth is under attack. Is
he a hero, or a psycho killer?
The Nice Guys
Writer-director Shane Black is the king of
the action comedy, getting his start by writing
the original Lethal Weapon back in 1987.
"Do you really wanna jump? Do you wanna?"
The Nice Guys, a lower-key buddy cop comedy
starring Ryan Gosling and Russell Crowe as
partners in '70s L.A., proves that Black is
back, and he hasn’t lost his gifts.
Green Room
Viewers are plunged into the hellish ordeal
experienced by a punk band who attract the
bloodthirsty ire of some murderous neo-Nazi
skinheads. Did we mention that Patrick Stewart
is the homicidal owner of the club where the
band is trapped?
Starring the late Anton Yelchin, Green Room
is equal parts smart and nasty—and one of
the more sinfully enjoyable indie efforts
of 2016.
Hail, Caesar!
Hail, Caesar!, which stars Josh Brolin as
a studio fixer in Hollywood’s golden age
on a mission to solve the disappearance of
a dopey movie star, played by George Clooney,
who's been drugged and abducted from the set.
Assembled with the typical Coen Brothers quirk,
it’s some of the most fun we’ve had at
the movies this year.
Everybody Wants Some!!
"You cool, man?"
With his 1993 cult classic Dazed and Confused,
Richard Linklater assembled an insightful
look at high school in the ‘70s. He picked
that thread back up with Everybody Wants Some!!
It offers a look at college life and packs
in a killer, era-appropriate soundtrack featuring
classic hits from Cheap Trick and Van Halen.
Deadpool
How do you make a Deadpool movie that embraces
the character's filthy comics persona while
still being broad enough money to prop up
a franchise? We still can't quite believe
they pulled it off, but Fox made it work.
The anti-hero, played by Ryan Reynolds, slashes
up bad guys and breaks the fourth wall with
equal abandon.
Midnight Special
Director Jeff Nichols and actor Michael Shannon
perfectly captured modern-day, middle-class
dread in 2011's Take Shelter. The pair reunited
in 2016 for Midnight Special, a movie about
a father racing to protect his son from outside
forces bent on taking advantage of his seemingly
superhuman abilities.
Thanks for watching! Subscribe to our YouTube
channel to watch more videos like the one
you just saw. And leave us a comment to let
us know what 2016 movie was your favorite
so far...